my plan for the day is to finish
upon methods we don't have much left but
I think they're really interesting
topics and then I have a notebook on
metrics and I think I won't go through
the entire notebook there's a lot of
material there what I thought I would do
is just go through the section that's on
kind of accuracy precision and recall
because I think if I do that not only
are those probably going to be the most
used metrics for projects in this course
but also you can kind of get a feel for
the higher level thing that I'm trying
to do which is to get you to think in a
kind of structured way about what your
metrics are doing what they're not doing
where they might have faults and so
forth so I'll do that and then Atticus
is going to take over Atticus has a very
exciting mini lecture on generalization
and adversarial testing as I've called
it here and we'll let that take whatever
time it takes and then just wrap up and
if there's a little bit of time that's
great you guys can just start to work on
your projects and chat with the members
of the teaching team who are here and
then next week contextual word
representations I'm gonna try to make
you responsible users of Bert and Elmo
in the transformer and then next
Wednesday we'll have a panel discussion
on NLU in industry and then Memorial Day
and then we kind of wrap up with some
other loose ends again in the spirit of
trying to introduce topics and content
that will help push your projects
forward that's basically what we're all
about from here on out oh we had a
wonderful discussion
I really appreciated all the comments
that people made last time about the
material there was a you know a bunch of
stuff that I'd never thought about and
that deserves further thought in the
meantime have any questions or concerns
occurred to you about the things we
covered which is kind of like we did all
of this stuff we covered a lot of ground
data organization cross validation
baselines
hyper parameter optimization and
classifier comparison so Google has that
theme busier which is they're hyper
parameter selection
I guess that's maybe what they use for
auto ml - is there some sense that those
things have kind of helped with the
hyper parameter tuning
that's still kind of privy only to these
big companies that have so much money
but they can just blast away a type of
parameters for whatever it was 400,000
hours or something I mean there is
definitely an element of blasting away
and kind of impressionistic leaf or SN
Li which is a leaderboard I kind of
follow closely there is a split you see
sometimes that simple models with
relatively few parameters have really
high scores and I think that's strongly
correlated with them being them
originating in companies like Google
that could do really wide cross across
you know hyper parameter validation to
find settings of the model that were
really really good and like
correspondingly you know these really
articulate intricate models that are
guided a lot by people's human intuition
about the data they do well with less
hyper parameter optimization because
they are guided by intuition so it's an
interesting kind of juxtaposition I
myself don't know much about Google
Vizier is that a public product or
something they just use internally it
was part of their learning to learn I
think like Watley or something in 2017
they published about it but I wasn't
sure
sort of how widely applicable as well
yeah I don't know I mean I remember it
from that quote I gave from the
healthcare paper where they spent two
hundred thousand hours doing
optimization using Vizier but I guess I
don't really know much about what it's
all about it would be great if they
alleviated this burden by making
resources available other things on your
mind all right let's do this final bit
here which is assessing models without
convergence which you could think of as
another way of calling out a lot of deep
learning models the background here is
kind of like in the simpler era of 2011
for this course when everybody was using
logistic regression convergence issues
rarely arose because those models mean
you might not even notice it but they do
have thresholds they do run for a number
of iterations typically but they tend to
converge right so you just kind of don't
think about the fact that this is one of
your high
parameters because they just finish up
possibly before whatever threshold was
set on the number of epochs so we didn't
talk about this too much until recently
but now with neural networks kind of at
center stage convergence too has taken
center stage because these models rarely
converge they can converge at different
rates between runs and then the other
side of this is that may be running to
convergence is not really what you want
because what you might implicitly be
doing with kind of early stopping is
some regularization that that is
benefitting your solution and then the
final point here is just that the
performance of these models on test data
is often heavily dependent on when you
decided to stop and how it related to
convergence so the bottom line here is
kind of like sometimes a model with a
low final error turns out to be great
and sometimes it turned out it turns out
to be worse than one that finished with
a higher error who knows right that's I
guess what I was gesturing at with this
notion of like stopping early as a way
of regularizing Oh as a way of avoiding
overfitting to the training data but
this poses a whole new set of problems
right because it's at least one more
hyper parameter but it's a very
complicated one to deal with because now
you're thinking about having to run
systems to varying degrees interacting
with all your other hyper parameters and
of course the more they need to run the
more expensive this all gets in some
generalized sense so one class of
responses that you could have to this
I've grouped under the heading of
incremental dev set testing so basically
the idea here is that as your model is
training incrementally say every hundred
epoch or every tenth or every thousandth
whatever you can afford run an
evaluation on a dev set and see how
performance is doing and I just want to
mention that all the PI torch models for
this course that are included in your
repo they can do this so if you give fit
an optional X dev and dev eater set of
arguments then they will run evaluations
on X dev and you can kind of collect
that information and make use of it you
could show a learning curve
or you could use it to make a decision
about where you want to stop and I will
say that in my view at least given my
understanding tensorflow is kind of
ahead of the curve in all of this if you
use the tensor flow classes for this
course then I was able to just piggyback
on the new estimator model framework and
its capabilities and they have lots of
sophisticated things in terms of like
automatically writing your model to disk
so that if you want to rewind back to an
earlier state of really good performance
it's easy to do that the PI torch models
are not currently set up for that kind
of thing but the spirit of all of this
is just that you have your dev set you
might as well see how you're doing on it
and use that to inform test set
evaluation it's worth emphasizing again
that absolutely under no circumstances
should you do this with your test set
that would just be like an incredibly
blatant form of T of cheating where you
decided to stop opportunistically when
you saw the best performance but that's
what your dev set is for so I encourage
a lot of this I mentioned before here
that you know the low error rate doesn't
always correspond to good performance
here's an actual pair of learning curves
I have macro f1 here and the number of
iterations and for whatever reason on
this run of the model performance got
really good and then kind of leveled off
meanwhile over here error versus
iterations the error just kept getting
lower and lower but obviously this was
arguably having a negative effect or no
effect at all even as this error went
way down and that's just because at a
certain point you start to over fit
through the training data
oh I mean I guess it's a wild world and
you might see that but versions of this
might be something that you actually use
as kind of debugging so for example if
your learning curve your sorry your
error doesn't look approximately like
this then there might be something wrong
in the optimization setting that's
causing it to oscillate or even like
have the error get larger and it would
surprise me if that corresponds to a
good behavior kind of over here on this
left panel and I guess the lesson there
is just you might observe both of these
things that's another advantage of
tensorflow is that with tensor board
monitoring you can see all of this and
kind of get a feel for what your model
is doing but certainly look at both and
don't take one as a proxy for the other
that's kind of my my overarching point
here here's what I think the best
response to all of this is right because
the way I was just describing things
before we were still kind of in the mode
of saying I know that my model varies by
epoch I know that that affects test set
performance but still what I want to do
for you is report one single number on a
test set and if you think open-mindedly
about this that's kind of misleading
because what I'm telling you is that
there's lots of variation along least
learning curves as you as you train on
more data so I think the best response
is to accept that incremental
performance plots like the one here are
really how we should be assessing these
models because that exposes much more
information about the variation that you
actually observe and can give you
actually new ways of arguing for your
model as I'll show you in a second
the other thing I would say is that in
deep learning you know in principle if
you think about the theory these models
should be capable of learning anything
so what we're really thinking about is
how efficiently they can learn or how
stable their learning patterns are and
so forth and that's probably ultimately
where your real argument lies and here's
a kind of example of this from my own
work from a paper that I did last year
with Nick Dingwall so the background
here just quickly is we were arguing for
this model called mittens mittens is a
warm start for glove the argue
is that mittens are warmer than gloves
and really the pitch here is that what
you could do is start from like vectors
that you had downloaded from the web and
then run glove on them with a kind of
retrofitting learning objective to
update them for a specialized domain and
in the paper we do this kind of updating
for a bunch of different domains and
what we're trying to do is show that you
can do well if you do that kind of
updating but the way that we actually
evaluate them is kind of extrinsic so
the evaluation is that they are inputs
to various kinds of other machine
learning models and in this case we're
doing a sequence prediction tasks for
healthcare where you're kind of talking
about people being diagnosed with
different diseases and the model is an
RNN that for each token is predicting
whether it's like talking about a
concern for a diagnosis or ruling out a
diagnosis or as an other tag or whether
it's a positive diagnosis for the
disease in kind of clinical texts the
kind of thing that you'd see you know in
an electronic health record so these are
RNs fundamentally the full story here is
that we didn't do a lot of hyper
parameter tuning because our rationale
was that would be expensive first of all
for these RNs because they need to run
for a long time for convergence and the
two models our main competition is like
mittens versus clinical text gloves so
glove just trained on the text we have
available and not given a warm start
from the downloaded vectors that's our
main competition and all we really care
about is the Delta between them really
we're trying to see whether mittens is
better and otherwise these RNs are kind
of the same like in you know and the
inputs are scaled in similar ways
mittens and these various flavors of
glove so we use that as an argument to
just set the hyper parameters like the
dimensionality to the network and its
activation function and so forth but we
did observe a lot of variation in how
these models would learn because of
randomization and their parameter
initialization and so forth so we felt
it was important to show these learning
curves and that's what we're doing here
by category along the x axis is the
number of training epochs and the y axis
is f1 and I like this really full
picture because if
step back I can say that we if you look
at macro averaged have a kind of modest
argument overall that for this data
mittens learns a bit faster so if you
can only afford to do like a thousand
training epochs then the warm start for
this domain is actually helping but over
time if you can run to ten thousand the
difference between those two models has
disappeared between clinical texts glove
and mittens but you can also see that no
matter how long you run these things
have kind of leveled out and both of
those models are better than generic
glove vectors or random initialization
right that's the yellow and the gray so
that's the kind of full picture but it
gets pretty nuanced if you look at these
different categories so like I'm not
sure that that model really that
argument really holds for concern for
example there it's very hard to see a
difference between the red and the blue
maybe it's a bit stronger for positive
up here where the error bars are tighter
I like this
you know kind of like in early phases of
learning mittens is good but in the
fullness of time a lot of the
differences disappear at least between
those two competitors it would be a very
different picture I would be giving you
a very different story here if we had
decided to just pick the best point of
performance for each one of these
categories or the best point of
performance for macro averaging right
there it might look like a stronger
cut-and-dry argument in favor of mittens
but you can see that that would be a bit
opportunistic right and so I kind of you
know I think the thing like open and
honest reporting of how these models are
doing this is like our attempt to do
that and so I don't know I guess I'm
saying that I would love to see plots
like this in papers you all produce I
recognize that there's often a lot of
pressure in terms of information
overload and in terms of culture to give
a single macro f1 number or something
like that but if you feel there's a room
for this kind of more nuanced thing then
go for it you have the teaching teams
full support I would say and this plot
here since all that's differing here is
the random
initialisation and other kind of random
things about how these models are
learning that brings us to this other
point here the role of random parameter
initialization right so you know you
when you set up the weights for your
model in these settings you'd do it with
random initialization in these kind of
non convex optimization problems that
initial setting might be determining a
lot about how the model ultimately fares
but I will say that even simpler models
can be impacted by this if there's
multiple optimal solutions then they
could get steered in one direction or
another a kind of startling result from
a couple of years ago is this paper that
kind of did a bunch of analysis of
recently proposed neural language models
and the striking finding of this paper
is that if you ran these systems a lot
of times then the differences between
them essentially disappeared because the
way in which they had been randomly
initialized was having a big impact on
the final outcome for the models and it
would kind of put a damper this paper on
the feeling that recent proposals were
vastly better than earlier ones because
kind of when it all washed out the
differences were small or non-existent
and this was all tracing two different
initializations this is sort of
disturbing also for statistical testing
different initializations can lead to
statistically significant differences
and there's a related thing here which
is kind of the extreme version of this
which goes under the heading of
catastrophic failure so you you have an
unlucky initialization of your model and
it leads to not only bad performance but
like effectively zero performance my
feeling is that the smart the good and
open thing to do is to report the number
of times that that happened maybe in the
pros of your paper so that you don't
destroy the results table but it is
important I think to be forthcoming
about how often this was happening and
how much it was shaping the final means
and confidence intervals that you
reported sorry these big differences and
people aren't going to be publishing you
know results where they're not you
stood at the art do you think that there
is this kind of like just random hill
climbing that happens because people all
around the world are basically doing
these random initializations every time
they attempt one of these papers and
occasionally people will get lucky and
some benchmark and that'll get published
and then someone else will get even
luckier late is that what you think is
happening or is that not really a big
concern I think it is happening and I
think it's a concern and that's sort of
the story not to impose too much on
these authors but that's kind of the
story of this paper here and that all of
it brings me to the idea that we should
be reporting things that look more like
this that show us the impact of all of
these different choices and not so
fixated on a single summary number
because it's probably overstating the
degree to which we're making an ex
herbal progress on these problems it's
kind of why I like again to bring up the
s and Li leaderboard there are so many
systems that have been entered onto that
leaderboard now that you can do the
thing of kind of informally doing a
meta-study
and saying okay broadly speaking which
classes of models are doing well and
like here they're the clear answer is
it's some kind of ensemble of deep
learning modular pieces so that even if
the individual numbers are kind of being
overstated the overall trend is clear
and to substantiate this a little bit in
the notebook I didn't reproduce it here
but there's a famous problem in in
neural networks the XOR problem which is
just the logical connective that gives a
1 to the cases where P and Q have
different truth values otherwise 0 and
it's famously not a problem that a
linear classifier can learn the other
one is if and only if where the values
have to be the same to get a truth value
of 1 and you like one of the original
arguments by the deep learning founders
just shows that you can learn XOR with a
kind of a shallow neural network and
that's great and it's cool and you
definitely can theoretically do this
thing that you can't do with a linear
model without adding a bunch of
interaction terms okay cool but in
reality if you run my little
feed-forward network it succeeds at this
eight of ten times and that's kind
that's entirely owing to the fact that
this is a small problem and so the
initialization really matters and you
could just run that and get a feel for
yourself but the extent to which this is
actually solved empirically so response
here yeah this kind of summarizes what
I've been saying so report scores from
multiple complete runs with different
randomly chosen initializations
and then summarize that variation with
confidence intervals or statistical
tests and then I want to return to this
pragmatic note that I keep sounding here
so arguably these observations are
incompatible with things like McNee Mars
tests which depend on one run and I
think that's true but I think we have to
balance that against the fact that if
your system takes two weeks to train
then more or less starting now you have
the opportunity to do just a few runs
and then McNee Mars test might be better
than nothing in terms of informing us
about differences so let's wrap this up
I think I can summarize everything that
we did last time in this time with a few
things here so your evaluation should be
based around a few systems that are
related in ways that illuminate your
hypotheses and help to convey what the
best models are learning that's the kind
of baseline stuff that we talked about
every model you assess should be given
its best chance to shine right
that's like hyper parameter tuning and
all of that stuff is trying to make the
strong argument in this way and then the
pragmatic note we need to be realistic
about how many experiments we can
actually afford to run afford in terms
of dollars or time or resources the test
set the test set should play no role
whatsoever in optimization or model
selection this is a note that we've
sounded a lot because we did all those
bake-offs the best way to ensure that
this this is to have the test set locked
away until the final batch of
experiments that will be reported in the
paper and the other thing that you can
do if you don't have a test set
is simulate that by careful across
validation setups this would be where
okay you have a fixed body of examples
you do cross-validation and report the
mean and the way you try to make a case
that you're kind of hands-off about all
of that is that you set up your models
with a lot of hyper parameter tuning and
let them run hands off and then just
report the final number and try to be
honest with yourself about the extent to
which you're going back and specially
advantaging the model that you're
favoring you kind of want this to be as
hands-off as possible and then of course
just report this regime very carefully
strive to base your model comparisons
and multiple runs on the same splits
especially if you're doing deep learning
stuff because a single model can perform
in very different ways on the same data
depending on optimization and moons you
know sunspots and whatever else is
happening in the universe all right did
that raise any new questions for you or
concerns or comments or I guess I guess
one major point of the analysis of
different the performance of various
model is to learn like sort of meta
learn what architectures are high level
thick features of a model are good for
the good performance on a certain task
but at the same time is it necessarily
bad that people get lucky and do happen
to do the random hill climb and and get
like successful models that way oh I
think it's not so the only bad part yeah
like getting lucky could be great and it
does show us something there's a setting
in which you win I think the part that
at least I was worried about it maybe
too is like if I do that special stuff
only for the model that I want to
advocate for because that's where you're
stacking the deck in your favor like I
run these models hundreds of times and
most of the time my model loses and I
report the situation in which my model
happened to win
and you you probably know in your heart
that that's not an honest reporting that
kind of thing and I think asking how
often is that happening out there in the
world and I guess I was saying more than
I would like
as my guess but what we can do is I kind
of push the community with our own
choices in the direction of reporting
all the mean and confidence intervals on
all of those runs and like actual
happier utilization there's other types
like that oh I get that like see to me
as an idea probably isn't that great but
he's there inside that could be gleaned
from finding what weights worked out
which ones didn't I'm sure there is yeah
no that's a great point and I feel like
as we get better at getting analytic
insights those good settings where you
got lucky will provide more and more
intelligence because you could what what
if you did report that for your problem
the standard thing was this kind of
initialization and the best settings
were the ones that deviated the most
from it but what if they had different
statistical properties and what if you
then took that lesson and applied it in
a systematic way and found that it
reproduced a lot then you could get an
initialization scheme named after you
which is real fame because then you get
your name in all these deep learning
packages okay let's do the metrics thing
but keep asking questions on Piazza and
office hours yeah I think it's great to
be discussing all this
but let's do one thing about metrics so
this is a massively long notebook and
that's why I say like let's talk about
basically just the first part of this
classifier metrics thing because that'll
be enough to give you a feel for my
thinking about this and kind of get that
discussion going and then if you're
doing a problem with regression or
sequence prediction then you can refer
to these later sections here which
introduce all of these metrics in just
the way I'm going to today and talk
about their trade-offs yeah here's the
overview of this so different evaluation
metrics encode different values in about
different values in the sense of like
what do we value of a system and they
also have different biases and
weaknesses no none of these metrics is
perfect because all of them are encoding
different values and values can vary so
you should choose your metrics carefully
and motivate these choices and when
writing up and presenting your work I
would love to see passages where even if
you've even if you're doing something
that's the default for your problem you
still to articulate why it's the choice
that you made the note book reviews some
of the most prominent metrics in NLP and
I try to define them but also articulate
what values they encode and what
weaknesses they have and also rapport
relationships between them because one
way in which this can be kind of
overwhelming is that basically the same
metric is described and given different
names in different ways when really the
differences don't mean much in your own
work you should not feel confined to the
metrics in this notebook right per my
first item you have the freedom to
motivate new metrics and use cases for
existing metrics depending on what your
goals are
now culturally if you're working on an
established problem then you'll feel a
lot of pressure from readers and
referees to use metrics that have
already been adopted for the problem and
there are even these little communities
within NLP that have like totally
settled on a single metric no matter how
problematic and so you could get in this
trap of feeling like you know there's a
problem but you still have to
report it you should feel free to argue
against those norms and motivate new
ones you might in your paper want to
report the old metrics as a kind of
foundation and then talk about why a new
metric is a better one for your problem
I kind of feel like I don't really work
in this area but for language modeling I
feel like everybody is in this state
with reporting perplexity so it's like
everyone does it because everyone
expects that everyone else will expect
that they do it but nobody believes in
it still report it and the other thing
I'll say just by way of high-level is
the sidekick model evaluation usage
guide here is great it has lots of notes
about how to make responsible use of the
metrics they've provided and they've
provided lots of them in the notebook
that I'm going through here I've hidden
a lot of this but I define redefine the
metrics just so that you can see how
they work
but my advice to you would be to use
this eye kit ones because they've been
more heavily tested and tend to have
more options for doing things so but
let's just do this classifier metric
thing and the kind of linger over this
and this is kind of nice because this is
the stuff that you've probably
encountered the most and feel like you
already fully understand and that my
idea would be that I want to kind of
problematize this for you so let's start
with the confusion matrix this gives a
complete comparison of how the observed
that is the gold labels here and the
predicted labels relate to each other
I'm sorry that's a bit small but I have
like a simple sentiment problem pause
neg neutral pause and egg nutrition
positive examples right 15 negative and
a thousand neutral correct those are the
diagonal elements and then the off
diagonal is saying like for ten of the
true positive cases the model predict
negative and for a hundred of the true
positive cases the model predicted
neutral right you guys have seen these
before I'm going to call this example
one
you should remember when you think about
these things
that your classifier probably did not
predict into this space it predicted a
probability distribution over those
three labels pause Megan neutral and to
construct this table you have to impose
a threshold you have to say that I'm
gonna for example pick the highest of
the probability values and just say that
is the true label and that is what
shaped this final picture here but that
is of course a meaningful thing to have
done if your classifier say it predicted
likes to make it easy think of a binary
problem where the threshold will be 50%
suppose your classifier reliably
predicts for the zero label that it's
like zero to 20% and then 20 to 40 for
the positive label you're confusin
confusion matrix will look like you've
got everything wrong when in fact with a
different threshold your model would be
perfect so keep that in mind and that
this can happen especially with very
imbalanced classes that the classifier
just kind of never predicts high values
for things even though it is
discriminating and I'm not going to go
into this today but metrics like average
precision and precision recall curves
they can expose exactly that kind of
behavior in your classifier and give you
a really strong argument that you're
doing well even though the default made
confusion matrix would look bad and the
other thing I would say is that we might
care about the full distribution and
that's being completely hidden by this
confusion matrix but this is nonetheless
the basis for the metrics that I want to
go over with you now so accuracy this is
the metric that we all probably think of
at some level when we think about
assessing how good a system is at least
before you enter this field you think
accuracy will be the right metric this
is just the sum of the correct
predictions divided by the sum of all
predictions and I have the same
confusion matrix here and I just
highlighted the diagonal because what
accuracy is doing is summing those
values and dividing by the total of all
the values in the table and so here this
with this classifier you get an accuracy
of 81% you know it's useful to just know
the bounds I did this for all the
metrics and here obviously it's zero two
one zero the worst one the best what
value is encoded by accuracy you might
argue that it encodes a kind of core
value that we have for classifiers that
is how often they're correct and in
addition as I'll show you in a second
the accuracy of a classifier on a test
set will be negatively correlated with
the negative cross entropy loss which is
a common law for classifiers so in in
that important sense of your classifier
is probably optimizing accuracy or
rather an inverse value of accuracy and
that does make it a very natural fit and
I want to return to that when we think
about how this is all interacting with
them hyper parameter tuning but just
keep in mind that even though we don't
favor accuracy as the metric it is what
your classifier is doing probably so
weaknesses of accuracy it does not give
a per class metric for multi class
problems and we might want that kind of
nuance but the more important thing is
that accuracy just completely fails to
control for size imbalances in the
classes so for example consider this
variant ear of the above classifier ex1
where the classifier only ever predicts
neutral because neutral is a large
category it looks like a really good
classifier from the point of view of
accuracy its accuracy is 0.87 for this
clip for this confusion matrix versus
0.8 one for the one before but I really
feel like this is a better model if you
think about actually discriminating
between the labels this looks better
than this one which is just stupidly
always guessing neutral and benefiting
from the fact that neutral is a massive
category and this is why we have never
used accuracy in this class because you
could only ever trust it even a little
bit for a completely balanced problem
make sense
and then the other part of this little
framework I've constructed here is just
what's related to accuracy and so I did
you won't just want to state that
accuracy is inversely proportional to
the cross entropy loss and the cross
entropy loss and in turn accuracy can
both be related to KL divergence and the
value of that is just that if your
classifier is predicting a probability
distribution you might also think about
learning from a probability distribution
and kind of really embracing the
probabilistic nature of your classifier
and of the data in which case you'd
probably use KL divergence as your
metric and it would also be what your
model was optimizing in some rescaled
sense so this is a kind of like nice
little network of related things that
very deeply connect with what your model
is doing and then we have this kind of
mismatch that it's what your model is
doing but it's probably not what you
want to report as your metric you know
we want to report something like
mackerel f1 but you can't in a
straightforward way optimize for macro
f1 so that's worth keeping in mind and
in my experience it's worth keeping in
mind because when you do hyper parameter
tuning you might do that tuning against
your true metric which is mackerel f1
and pick the model that maximizes that
value but you should remember that your
model is doing something different and
might actually be steering you outside
of the space that you actually want to
be in for your problem
that's a kind of limitation of this
niche mismatch that we're encountering
make sense any questions about that this
okay
I'm afraid not because the macro f1 is
this kind of holistic thing about how
you're doing on an entire subset of your
data and so it would have to be correct
me if I'm wrong here but some kind of
loss that was more like a reinforcement
learning loss and not something that was
directly like stainable as a
differential loss on your classifier
yeah that kind of problem though with
accuracy
you know like imbalance classes this is
what leads to precision and recall and
the reason I like that we're doing this
one in particular is that again and
again through the notebook you see that
precision and recall is what people have
in their back in the back of their minds
so like when you get to like blue scores
blue scores are kind of precision recall
you know word level act was what's
sometimes called accuracy is also a
precision recall balance and even some
of the regression metrics are kind of
trying to do something that's like
balancing precision and recall so this
is kind of the heart of it so precision
in these things is the sum of the
correct predictions divided by the sum
of all the guesses as a per class notion
and in our confusion matrices it's the
diagonal values divided by the column
sums that's what I've indicated with
this coloring here that we're kind of
operating column wise so here are the
precision values for this example one
that we've been dealing with so high
neutral low negative and modest positive
for our problematic all neutral
classifier precision is kind of
undefined because we made zero guesses
going down so we end up dividing by zero
the standard thing is to map those to
zero but you should keep in mind that it
was strictly speaking undefined and this
this affects the bounds if you think
very carefully and mathematically you
can't quite say that the bounds are zero
to one without this caveat about what
you do in the case that you have an all
zeros column like this and then we have
high precision for this neutral category
there's that caveat there about the
bounds what value is encoded by
precision the way I would articulate
this is that it encodes a conservative
value in that it penalizes incorrect
guessing on a per class basis the
weaknesses of precision Precision's
dangerous edge case is that you can
achieve very high precision for a
category by rarely guessing it so
consider this one here example 3 what I
did is just make a minor change where I
have it predict once for each of these
and it happens to be correct I think
this is not a good classifier and some
intuitive sense but its precision is
perfect for positive and negative
because it just kind of withheld
judgment for all but these two cases
where it could do well yeah compare that
with example one where you know the
precision was pretty low here but it's
intuitively kind of got a better grip on
the positive and negative categories so
the counter port part of precision is
recall recall is the sum of correct
predictions divided by the sum of all
true instances again per class and in
our confusion matrices it's the diagonal
divided by the row sums so here the
recall values for example one important
point about all of these metrics that
are related to F scoring is that recall
trades off against precision and that's
the way in which each of them is kind of
making up for the faults of the other so
here's that example three again remember
we make one guess for positive one for
negative so precision is perfect but
recall is dismal for both of those
categories because in withholding its
guesses for those classes it ends up
making a bunch of recall mistakes and as
a result like the F 1 for this is going
to be pretty bad recall is straight
forward bounds and I would say this is a
nice balance here so recall encodes a
permissive value in penalizing only
missed true cases whereas precision was
conservative recall is permissive
the weaknesses of recall it's dangerous
edge case is that you can achieve very
high recall for a category by always
guessing it and that could mean lots of
incorrect guesses but since recall kind
of intuitively if you think about the
calculations it sees only the correct
guesses so it doesn't really mind about
this over guessing you can see this here
actually so for the neutral category it
made a lot of guesses about neutral but
it missed none of them and so it's
recall is actually very high down here
it's one yeah it just always gets a
category and you're sure to have perfect
recall that's the sum of it but in turn
your precision will be hit someone F
scores which we've used pervasively in
this course they kind of codify this
balance between precision and recall so
the standard way of doing this is to
combine precision and recall the other
harmonic mean with a value beta that can
be used to emphasize precision or recall
and we've done the default thing of
always balancing them equally and that's
F 1 down here where you just pick the
value 1 and it simplifies down to this
expression but you know again you should
be thoughtful about which one whether
you default to this equal balance and
one way to think about this is like so a
bunch of people in this course are
working on things like hate speech and
toxicity so just as a quick use case
suppose you're developing a system
that's going to help with interventions
for that problem it's an open question
whether you want the system to be biased
in favor of precision or recall if you
have very few human resources for doing
manual review of your model predictions
then you want a favorite precision
because you want to make really good use
of those humans and have them see only
things that your model has high
confidence are like toxic but that's
going to have the trade-off that a lot
of messages that really ought to have
been filtered out of your community are
going to make it in because what you
were optimizing for there at a higher
level it's like saving human time
conversely if you have a whole fleet of
humans who can help you with this task
then you could be biased in favor of
recall if they don't mind reviewing a
lot of scores a lot of texts where
actually it was fine to just let them
onto the platform it's really going to
depend on what you're trying to do but I
think whatever your actual situation is
it's unlikely that precision and recall
are perfectly balanced so I guess the
only justification for us perfectly
balancing them all the time is that we
don't know what else you're trying to
accomplish in the world so here's an
example these are the f scores here and
I think they kind of align with what we
think of about how the model is doing on
these tasks there's for example two and
RN strictly speaking but for positive
and negative because you had undefined
precision for for positive and negative
the F score is also undefined but
typically that will be mapped to zero or
like for sidekid it will be mapped to
zero and it'll print out a bunch of
warnings for you and here's example
three where we had such high precision
for positive and negative but very low
recall and that's nicely reflected in
the fact that the f1 scores for pause
and neg are also very low bounds are 0 &
1 and you have a guarantee that the it
will be between precision and recall
what's the value encoded by f scores
here's one way that I tried to
articulate it so it's an attempt to
summarize how well your classifiers
predictions for a certain class K align
with the true instances where what I'm
trying to bring out with a line is like
not only giving you credit for the hits
but also detracting for the misses in a
kind of in the case of f1 in a symmetric
way and intuitively for all these things
precision and recall are keeping each
other in check somehow for these
calculations and as and if you go
through the notebook on your own you'll
see that theme recur again and again
outside of the classification context
what are the weaknesses of f scores so
there's no normalization for the size of
your data set within the class that
you're focused on or outside of it and
then the other thing that you might
highlight here is that for a given F
score if you think about like focusing
on pause here
pause f1 pays attention to the all the
row values and all the column values but
it ignores everything that's off of
those rows and columns all the values
and to kind of illustrate that what I
did is here I have example one where
down here in the corner you have a
thousand and then for this data set I
changed that to a hundred thousand for
pause an egg f1 is the same across these
two data sets and that's worth keeping
in mind because obviously these are very
different problems these are very
different data sets and the classifier
is doing very different things because I
made this so massive but f1 was
insensitive to that only the neutral f1
changed because of course that value is
on its row and it's column but keep that
in mind right when you do this f1 you're
kind of ignoring one aspect of the data
when you think about a per class basis
related to F scores so die similarity
for binary vectors which you might
remember from the first unit and is
often used to assess kind of how well
you those predictions align on a set
theoretic way that's equivalent to f1
especially if you think on the kind of
per token basis for a vector of
predictions and then as I said the
intuition of F scores is common let's do
just a few of these macro average things
so macro averaged F scores that's the
mean of all the F scores for each
category that's the one that we've
always used here's a quick example you
guys know about this one I mean
basically what we're doing here is just
taking all the per class F values and
averaging them and that kind of goes
here to the weaknesses so I typically
Ida fault to macro f1 because
like the fact that it's giving each
class no matter its size equal weight in
the final calculation and the
justification for that is that in NLP
very often it's the smallest classes
that we care about the most and so it
makes no sense to give more weight to
the ones that are large because maybe
they're easy and uninteresting but you
should keep in mind that in in thinking
about macro averaging your systems
metrics might look out of step with how
it actually performs in the world
because if I just turn it loose on real
data that have the same class balance as
the data set that it was developed on
then you know the fact that it makes a
lot of correct predictions is going to
be a meaningful thing in terms of people
experiencing the system and just because
it's a large class doesn't mean that
it's any less meaningful if you think
about performance in the world so in a
funny way your macro average score could
end up overstating how well you actually
do because you know a tiny class that
you never experienced as a user with the
system was contributing just as much to
the kind of example that it sees all the
time and practice so that's worth
keeping in mind in terms of practical
applications and then I think the these
two kind of balance each other so you
can both over and under state how well
your system is doing by doing macro
averaging but nonetheless I think when
we think about system evaluation in this
context the macro average choice is a
really good one there are also weighted
F scores psych it reports these which
just gives a weighted average based on
the class size and then there are micro
average scores and micro average scores
with just a few qualifications are
exactly identical to accuracy and so
they inherit all the problems of
accuracy and that makes them a kind of
dis favorite option and in fact you know
by and large why not just report
accuracy as an opponent as opposed to
choosing the more convoluted micro
averaging approach but I did include it
here for completeness
and I think I'll stop there because I
want to leave plenty of time for Atticus
and I also feel like now you're armed or
the kind of framework for thinking about
this what value does it encode what
bounds does it have and what are its
strengths and weaknesses it's worth
asking that for any metric that you
encounter and certainly if you decided
to propose your own metric you'd want to
kind of fully command that space of
different considerations okay
unless there are questions yeah the
weighted scores will have that fact that
they'll favor large classes just like
micro averaging would that might be what
you want to do it really depends I guess
I'm encouraging you to think about what
you're trying to achieve what your
system is trying to do and then choose a
metric accordingly and my justification
for macro averaging is just that we
often do care about those small classes
we really want to get traction on them
and and that and that can be kind of
dispiriting if you're doing really well
improving on the small classes but you
chose weighted or micro f1 and you just
don't see any impact on the number it's
like I doubled the performance I doubled
my F score on this tiny class and
weighted Mac and weighted f1 says I
don't care it's too small for me to care
I go up by a little bit whereas the
macro one will reflect all of those
gains yeah if you want to develop say
like a conversational agent that appears
human I just basically passed the Turing
test what type of metric would be best
suited for something like that oh that's
so funny to think you know Turing's
answer was the Turing test and he did
have some kind of accuracy calculation
right wasn't it like fooling it like two
out of three times or something I forget
was it two out of three since it's a
classification where there's a human and
a machine they have to call the Machine
the human and the human machine like
they have to get the label swapped so
that was his metric but the lesson of
time is that the
that people confuse humans for robots
and the reverse all the time did we tell
that story I guess we didn't from the
first ever real Turing test the human
who was most often rated as a machine
was a Shakespeare expert she could
answer any question about Shakespeare
and people's rationale was no human
could know that much all right let me
turn it over to Atticus to continue
these themes
hello I'm Atticus I'm one of your course
assistants and I'm gonna give you a
little presentation on evaluating and
all you models with harder
generalization tasks all right
so going through this I'm going to start
by just kind of over viewing the
framework that Chris has been talking
about which is just a standard
generalization framework of arbitrarily
setting aside training samples and
testing examples from large data set and
then I'm going to introduce you to some
adversarial testing literature where
people are trying to develop more
challenging generalization tasks to
probe at the capabilities of NLU models
and then I will conclude by sharing some
of my research with you cool so this
should be a framework you're very
familiar with by this point it's what
we've been doing in our homeworks and in
most of our Bake off's where we find a
data set for it and NLU tasks and then
we just arbitrarily split this data set
into training and testing and we train
models on the training set and evaluate
on unseen testing examples but actually
in bake-off 3 we did something a little
bit different than this so in bake-off 3
if you remember we did nli on single
words we were just trying to predict an
entailment relation four pairs of words
and in our edge disjoint case we
followed this standard framework where
we arbitrarily set aside some examples
for testing and some for training but in
our word disjoint case we did something
a little bit different where we ensured
that in training and testing no words
would be shared between these two sets
which creates a harder generalization
task as it expects models to generalize
to unseen vocabulary so kind of like the
high-level theme of this presentation is
that I'm going to encourage you to
consider breaking from these standard
evaluations and try to create
generalization tasks that are difficult
well motivated and that answer specific
questions about model capabilities so to
get introduced into the adversarial
testing literature we're going to start
with the example of question answering
so consider the research question can a
model learn to comprehend a passage of
text so this is a very high-level and
ambitious research question and people
here have actually tried to answer it by
creating the Stanford question answer
dataset which is an awesome resource
that you might want to use in your
projects so examples in this data set
look like this where there is a passage
a question and an answer the input is
going to be the passage of text and the
question and the output will be the
answer in this case it's about a passage
about football question about a
quarterback the answers Jarnell away so
you might think to answer our research
question can a model learn to comprehend
a passage of text that if a model
achieves human level performance on this
data set then it is able to comprehend
passages of text so if you do think that
then you're in luck plenty of models
have beaten humans at this task so you
know we're done question answering
solved like everything's great and no
more work to do but unfortunately it's
not actually quite that simple
so you might have a suspicion that these
models don't understand language quite
as deeply as you might hope they do and
GA at all actually devised an experiment
to see whether this is the case
they take training examples from the
squad data set and they systematically
perturb them to create a new adversarial
test set that they then evaluate models
on and using this as a new evaluation
metric so our example before with the
football we have a model prediction of
John LA which is the correct answer but
what they do is they append a single
misleading sentence to the passage to
trick the model and to thinking that
Jeff Dean is the quarterback that the
question is asking about and which is
just incorrect so when they generate a
new adversarial test set using this
technique they find that 16 published
models trained on squad drop from a 75%
test a 75% f1 score on the original test
set down to a 36% f1 score on this new
adversarial test set so sad question
answering is not solved which you might
have suspected so a natural idea is
we've identified a hole and the
generalization capabilities of models
trained on the squad dataset so to patch
this hole you say okay let's just take
these types of examples and include them
in training and this does work when we
include these types of examples in
training those models learn to ignore
the final sentence and they now this
patched model will now make the correct
prediction of John Elway but these
models this new patched model trained on
these types of examples is now
vulnerable to a different adversarial
testing set one where we just prepend
the sentence instead of appending it and
so now we see that this problem seems to
be deeper than just throwing in more
training data and having the model
become more robust that different
perturbations being trained on one
perturbation of the data doesn't
generalize to even similar perturbations
like this and so oh yeah like did yes or
they didn't do it manually so they're
it's a process of
chemically and then I think it's
verified by mechanical Turks that it's
consistent with the passage so they have
like an algorithmic generation process
for these types of sentences that are
misleading but then I believe that they
have their own mechanical Turks that go
in and verify whatever sentence they put
in is going to be consistent with
everything yeah I think they did do
another experiment it's not this one
it's I think it's in the same paper
where they just add tokens arbitrarily
don't have to be grammatical or anything
just to try to make the sent the models
fail and they get the f1 score down to
6% on that adversarial testing data but
you also might have some like I mean I
think this one's a little more
convincing and that this is English and
the other experiment that gets it down
to 6% is kind of like throwing at random
stuff that's not even really going to be
grammatical English yeah and also
something you can look at is squad 2.0
tries to address this make it a little
harder by adding the option to say oh
there is no answer to the question in
this passage cool anymore good so we're
gonna move from question answering to
nli where in the last couple of years
hmm oh sorry all possible perturbations
train on those like when will you be
able to same thing you know I think
that's a good question that's an
actually an experiment that I was really
interested when I read this paper is not
prepending uh pending but what have you
had a training and testing data where
you inserted this misleading sentence at
every possible location in the paragraph
because then you could think that you
know I'm not sure if the tech models
would even be able to like generalize
across those two things but ya know I
think that's really interesting because
well also it's important to remember
that this is like one way to like mess
with the model but of like an infinite
class
of ways to mess with this model so yeah
I definitely think that's like an
interesting question all right so moving
on to nli so in the last couple years
there have been like a growing number of
more difficult generalization tasks that
are trying to expose the fragility of
models trained on the SLI and multi
analyte datings data set so one of these
experiments tries to isolate the
capability of models to perform lexical
semantics reasoning so what they do to
create adversarial testing examples is
they take a premise from the SN Li data
set they take a single word in that
premise they exchange it for another
word to generate a hypothesis sentence
and then that is the adversarial example
so you can see there are three examples
here and each of these examples the
label for the sentence is directly from
a relationship between a pair of words
and in this paper they expose that
models don't have quite the robust range
of lexical semantics reasoning that you
would hope they would when being trained
on these massive naturalistic data sets
so that actually gives in more less
about their paper and more into the
nature of how SNL I was created so SNL I
was created with image captions direct
describing literal scene and what terkoz
were told to do is generate a caption
that must be true so they're given a
caption of an image without that image
there to generate an entailment
relationship they say they are asked to
describe a sentence that must be true of
the scene for a contradiction
relationship they are asked to generate
a sentence that is not true of this
scene and so that kind of like results
in this more like fuzzy idea of
contradiction than a kind of like strict
logical idea of contradiction
so what's adversarial about it is that
so these these pairs don't occur in the
SLI dataset only the first sentences do
and then they just take a single word
and they exchange that word for
something else so this could be
something that might occur in SLI but I
guess that's kind of the idea around
adversarial testing is that like it
should be similar enough to what we're
training on that it's a justified task
but the interesting part is they fail on
these compared to the SNL I test set so
I guess what makes it adversarial is
they're doing worse than they are on the
actual SLI test set so yeah yeah so yeah
so actually in this paper they have a
bunch of different they break it down to
different classes of words they work
with they have like planets like fruit
animals and so pi class some of the
classes they do very well on and then
some of the classes they seem not to be
exposed to those types of words as much
and so you can actually see a full
breakdown so if you were to actually use
like for example they have like one
thing they do is plan it so like
replacing Venus with Pluto and it seems
as that model is trained on SLI just are
really bad at that I guess because it's
down to like ten percent or something
but in other classes of words that I'd
guess are much more familiar they get
above what they get on the test set for
a sandal I so yeah I think it's a good
idea to really like take a look at the
details and these types of papers
because they like really can expose like
a range of nuanced capabilities so
moving on from lexical semantics there's
also experiments that try to determine
whether models are capable of
compositional semantics so here's a two
examples from this paper by Annie and
Wang so the first one they just take the
subject and the object and they swap
those two and so a woman is pulling a
channel and sliding snow child's pulling
a woman on set and snow and then in this
example what they do is they take a
premise sentence from SNL I and they
take an adjective in that sentence and
just move it to a different now
and so we both well we all understand
that these sentences are not in the
entailment relation because moving words
matters a lot that's kind of the whole
thing around compositional semantics but
what they've found is by doing this they
trick the models that are trained on SNL
I and the they often mistake these types
of examples for entailment relationships
because they think oh yellow yellow
those are similar words entailment yeah
and so another experiment isolates a
specific compositional frame it's I
think a little more like specific than
the other ones I was talking about where
it's just like the X is more Y than the
Z and so it's just found that as model
it's trained on SNL I just can't do
these kind of examples and this one
makes like a little more set isn't as
surprising to me because it's like a
very particular compositional frame that
I don't think would occur that much when
with literal image captions so yeah so
yeah so something you might be wondering
is like if they don't learn lexical
semantics and they don't learn
compositional semantics what are we
really doing here right and I guess what
I would guess is what I would say is
that models are learning a specific
slice of lexical semantics and/or
compositional semantics that is kind of
hand-tailored
to the SNL eye test set which the
community has been hill-climbing on
since its release and so I think this is
actually an exciting thing for your
guys's projects because it's kind of
intimidating to try to get a new
state-of-the-art score on SNL I data set
but for these adversarial testing data
sets
no one's been hill climbing on them so I
think there's a lot more room for
innovation and improvement that you
could do in your projects all right so
now I'm going to move on from
adversarial testing on to and share a
little bit of my own research so in my
own research I've been constructing
artificial natural language inference
datasets and they have examples that
look like this so like every tall human
doesn't
kick any large rock contradicts no human
angrily kick some rock so they're like
pretty complicated and hard to parse as
humans but this is kind of how they look
there's two quantifiers negation
adjectives adverbs and my kind of
original intent with this data set was
to stress test and align models with
learning these kind of like logical
sentences and so oh also I designed a
task specific model which is I called a
comp tree NN model which kind of jointly
composes a premise and hypothesis
together by aligning all their words and
then composing them together up this
tree structure and so there's just a
task specific model that should be
particularly good at doing this kind of
reasoning and so the first thing I did
was just do a standard evaluation on my
data where I arbitrarily set aside some
examples for testing and some examples
for training and as you can see from
this results table standard neural
models and my fast specific model all
achieve very high accuracy on this
standard evaluation split and while when
I did some digging I found that the
standard neural models failed to encode
the identity of verbs nouns adverbs and
adjectives which is a pretty serious
flaw and my TAS specific model performs
perfectly what I realized was that my
standard evaluation on my dataset was
far easier than I expected it to be the
when I thought about it more I realized
that every combination of quantifiers
and negation and modifiers occur in my
training data set because I have a
hundred nouns a hundred verbs 100
adjectives so all these complex function
words are going to appear in every
possible order during training and so a
model that could do well is just one
that memorizes these quantifiers and
negation and then just assigns them
labels so what I decided to do is I
wanted to construct a more challenging
training and testing split that really
precisely ask a question about what a
model is able to do and we're gonna just
keep it very high-level on what a
baseline model that performs natural
logic reasoning is but I constructed a
simple baseline model that does perform
natural logic reasoning and I used this
model to kind of implicitly define an
idea of fairness so I have a simple
baseline model and I consider our
training data set to be fair if this
simple baseline can learn a perfect
solution from the training data with the
idea of being that neural models if
they're able to perform the type of
reasoning my baseline model is able to
form should succeed at the same
generalization tasks and what I found
was that standard neural models fail
miserably at this new more challenging
generalization task and that even my
task specific model fails to achieve
perfect performance which was pretty
interesting that even something with a
hard encoded tree structure wasn't able
to solve this task and so I guess the
kind of narrative here is that at first
I used a standard and valuation which
was interesting but by breaking away
from that kind of standard framework I
was able to ask like a far more deep
question about the capabilities of my
models and so that's kind of just the
high-level moral of this story is you
should like think deeply and carefully
about what you're learning from your
experiments because often they're going
to be far easier than you expect them to
be and you should consider breaking away
from this kind of standard evaluation of
arbitrarily creating a training and test
set to create more challenging
generalization tasks that answer
interesting specific questions thank you
[Applause]